signori oggi playstation 5 livello
superiore di gaming partiamo derek
volevano scrivere the rock hanno
sbagliato non importano importante il
gameplay la i demo cioè una demo
addirittura ma sono sicuro che si
tratterà come meritiamo come cultori
videoludici moderni un'ora di buio
partiti bene sembra un amnesia c'è stato
mezz'ora di buio e poi è partito così va
bene sono mettevi niente si capirà di
più
comunque credo di essere caduto dal
soffitto a questo punto va bene è ben
chiara la fir first da sci d'acqua
velocemente va bene ti puoi portare in
giro le scatole come una cosa [ __ ]
perché potrei per qualche strano motivo
uscire da dove sono arrivato ma no
questo dovrebbe essere sangue o qualcosa
del genere
se sta roba qua cosa dovrebbe
significare mi ho preso del fuoco
non basta sinistra cioè aumentata la
cosa del fuoco let's go il san mauro in
hindi snellissima devi stare fermo
mentre leggo e non sto facendo niente
muoviti così il sangue readings iniziato
a perdere vita ho iniziato a prender
vita
ciao amici devo trovare una chiave non
ho capito però iniziata perché perdo
vita così successo
ok io trovare una scala per arrampicarmi
li giustamente perché non servivano i
che vedo degli occhi in questo quadro
con servivano le scatole per sel per
andare da su ecco la chiave
l'ho trovata l'ho trovata l'ho presa ho
aperto la porta io vorrei andare a
vedere la tv chi c'era lido vero prima
perché non ho ben capito
salve ho una chiave non ho paura di
usarla l'hack è male perché mi perde la
vita a caso hanno forse il mio battito
cardiaco quello con questa chiave apro
la porta che miss fa scoprire il codice
va bene alla bat caverna
non sono sempre qua in realtà ragazzi
non sono nato nessuna parte
semplicemente devo capire dove mettere
st chiave se non ve la devo infilare nel
deretano qua le leve l'ho capito cosa
fate
secondo me possiamo ritrovarci però un
altro giorno ma no noi siamo temerari
riproviamoci adesso mi fa piacere che un
gioco simpatico almeno quello allora
ripartiamo perché non ho capito niente
mi è saltato in bocca un tizio forse
forse il battito cardiaco serve per
mandare via al tizio non lo so non ho
capito bene va bene la chiave sta qua la
porta quarta volta apriamo st porta qui
perché quella di prima non mi va bene ok
non ho ben capito se le nostre cose che
purtroppo per terra proprio a c'è un
modo per ritirare le braccia perfetto
buono a sapersi ragazzi ritirate le
braccia quando ricapita
ok quindi non devo non devo farci una
l'allarme perché se suona l'allarme si
incazzano i vostri sa bene allora niente
allarme suonato ma sta facendo michael
jackson sto manichino che cos'è sta roba
qua
demonio senza offesa e senza fede gli
facciamo lega è difficile che devo dire
sarà chiara la prima vedere se
riscontrare in questa porta devo capire
cosa fa un cenno a scala c'è una botola
che si apre in quella maniera lì come
avevo detto a belen è chiusa mi fai
capire cosa devo tirare quadri preciso
quella destra giusta o sbagliata va bene
qual è quella destra sta pian piano ci
arriva
magari se vado tipo qua in fondo foto
sarkis le foto sono le chiavi che chiavi
hanno aperto st porta qua 3421 perfetto
3 4 2 1 3 4 2 1 per la corrente 3 4 2 1
3 4 2 non ve lo ricordate lo ricordo non
ricordo
vai vai vai mannaia la morte ha visto
non mi ha visto andiamo in questa stanza
prima tiro giù le leve
apro la porta vado avanti prendo il
codice ed esco cioè la pinza ho trovato
le pinze non so bene cosa servano
vabbè è sparito il tizio del fadalto e
ogni tanto se ne va esce eccolo lo zio
vabbè io ho le pinze non so bene cosa mi
servono però le tengo 23 49 34 tempo a
madre puoi andartene per favore fai
qualcos'altro della tua misera vita
nell'altra stanza anci indiano è diamo
solo dove serve a fa vj bravo ma almeno
ci passa in quella porta torna indietro
ci passa lui passa dentro le porte vabbè
dai dai dai 234 1349 trovato 12341 sia
aperta non si apre non si apre è rotto e
rotolo aperto
se da un lato l'ho fatto però questo non
ho ben capito uso aperto prova va bè
ragazzi sono uscito a prendere manichino
sentite bastano tanto è inutile la mia
vita non ha senso next gioco e quindi
ragazzi
ieri avete visto that shaped per chi non
l'avesse visto e quindi dove dura un
minuto e mezzo che ho fatto scegliere
una mezzo trovata vabbè comunque questo
è il primo video che ho fatto su the
trip c'è la prima volta che ci ho
giocato e non sapevo fosse un troll l'ho
registrato lo ho montato pensando di
giocare un gioco vero horror ve lo
lascio perché secondo me la prima volta
che ci ho giocato meglio e stata
divertente però devo ammetterlo un'unica
robe che è infatti bile visto che gli
spazi sono due e sto tipo ma oli o qua è
quindi impossibile molto figo that
schweppes prego questo mi sembra carino
giorgia a vederlo così e quindi io che
sono l'ispettrice in questo hotel c'è
ancora il killer va bene permesso
notiamo subito che nell arredamento che
bella ascensore non c'ha manco i tasti
speriamo che tutto il resto del gioco
abbia un senso
a quanto pare no sa bene salve
no no no hey hey hey ma veramente cosa
ho visto valore ma è più grande e troll
videoludico della storia tech softline
in via de rose ma veramente si è
schiantata sul vaso 9 devo rifare non me
l'aspettavo mai una cosa del genere non
me l'aspettavo ma line tornata pure bene
era una bella trama dai look chic è il
più grande degli mirror mai visto nella
storia ma se
no dai ragazzi c'è massimi mi piace al
bimba immediatamente alberto navarro già
che ti chiami alberto navarro secondo me
un oscar lo meriti ma poi cos'è cosa mi
stai dando nella mia vita questa cosa e
arte grazie alberto navarro quindi
ragazzi spero che la vita vi sia
piaciuto come al solito se vi è piaciuto
al 100 commento è un bel mi piace al
video quali siti iscrivetevi e noi come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo da
ragazzi
[Musica]
no